this video is sponsored by skinceuticals
hi it's michelle wong of lab muffin
beauty science chemistry phd and skin
care nerd
in today's experiment we'll be comparing
the antioxidant properties
of skinceutical c for really with two
competitive vitamin c serums
skinceutical c for really contains a
powerful antioxidant blend
that can neutralize free radicals free
radicals are substances that get
produced
in our skin throughout the day from
things like pollution
and uv rays from the sun free radicals
are
really reactive substances that can
damage everything inside your skin
antioxidants are substances that can
soak up the free radicals before they
can damage your skin
we'll be using three beakers containing
water
and we'll be using iodine as the free
radicals
i'll be putting one drop of each of our
three serums
into the beakers we'll start with c
ferylic
and one drop of each of the competitor
serums
now i'll be adding 10 drops of the
iodine to show the free radicals
as you can see the brown color turned
back to clear showing that the free
radicals were successfully neutralized
in our second beaker you can see the
brown color remains showing that it
hasn't successfully gotten rid of all of
our free radicals
we can see our third beaker also goes
clear showing that the free radicals
were again successfully neutralized
now we don't just have free radicals at
the start of the day we also get more
free radicals in our skin throughout the
day
as we're exposed to more pollution and
more sunlight
so i'm going to be adding more drops of
iodine to demonstrate this
the beaker containing c furylic has now
turned clear
showing that our extra free radicals
were also neutralized
unsurprisingly since the antioxidant was
already used up by the original free
radicals
our second beaker isn't able to
neutralize the extra free radicals
i'm going to be adding more drops of
iodine to our third beaker as well
as you can see our third beaker is also
unable to neutralize the extra free
radicals
now we can use the ce furuli to
neutralize the extra free radicals
in our second two beakers
so we can see that c pharylic acid can
neutralize free radicals throughout the
day
as well as reverse free radical damage
so hopefully you can now understand why
skinceuticals is the antioxidant
authority
thanks for watching